Ja, erstmal verspricht der Hersteller da an der Stelle eine super sichere Kommunikation. Wenn man anfängt mit Whistle.am zu kommunizieren, dann wurde einem verkauft, dass danach, naja, über sichere Verschlüsselungsalgorithmen, die dann auch groß auf der Webseite aufgeführt wurden, die Kommunikation abgesichert sein soll, Ende zu Ende. Und nachdem man da so ein bisschen einen Blick drauf geworfen hat, hat man eigentlich relativ schnell festgestellt, irgendwas stimmt an diesem Konzept nicht. Also der erste Punkt war, dass ich mir so ein bisschen die Webseite angeguckt habe. Ein Bekannter hatte das irgendwo verlinkt und meinte, das wäre ja ein spannendes Projekt. Und dann habe ich auf diese Webseite geguckt, da diese schöne Grafik gefunden, wo sie zeigen, wie sie das alles verschlüsseln. Und mein erstes Problem war, dass ich die eigentlich überhaupt nicht verstanden habe. Und man konnte eigentlich da schon relativ gut sehen, dass da irgendwie nicht so ganz verstanden wurde, was das auf die Hersteller ist, was wir selber nicht ganz verstanden haben, was sie da tun.
Jetzt hast du das sozusagen auch noch weiter ausgearbeitet und auch ein bisschen die Kommunikation dieser Software angeguckt und hast dich dann für die, wie wir es dir vorgestellt haben, Full Disclosure entschieden. Also du bist sofort an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen, hast nicht erst mit den Leuten gesprochen. Warum hast du dich dafür entschieden?
Einerseits war das ein bisschen ein Unfall. Also ich hatte gar nicht vor, das so aufzuhängen, dass das so eingeschlagen ist. Damit hatte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet. Andererseits war es so, dass ich mir diese Software angeguckt habe, habe dann entschieden, ja, guckst du dir jetzt mal an, was da so über die Leitung geht, habe mir das auf einem Handy installiert und habe dann einfach mal die Pakete, die da so unterwegs waren, mitgelesen und habe relativ schnell gesehen, das sieht ein bisschen komisch aus, das musst du dir mal genauer angucken. Habe mich dann dazwischen gehängt und habe dann relativ schnell festgestellt, dass an dieser Software so viel kaputt ist, dass man da eigentlich gar nicht mehr anfangen braucht zu flicken. Also von einem Bug möchte ich da an der Stelle schon gar nicht mehr reden. Und der Punkt ist, dass da natürlich auch die Benutzer sofort betroffen sind. Was wird davon geredet? Ja, wir haben hier eine super sichere Kommunikation. Wenn ich jetzt, ihr habt es vorhin angesprochen, wenn ich jetzt da hingehe und sage, ja, ihr habt jetzt zwei Wochen Zeit da was zu machen und dann schickt mal einen Patch oder so, ist das natürlich ein Punkt, das ist, wenn es um persönliche Kommunikation geht, wenn es darum geht, Kommunikation abzusichern und sich auf der anderen Seite herausstellt, dass diese ganze Kommunikation so offen ist, dass da grundsätzlich mit ein bisschen Sachverstand jeder mitlesen kann, dann stellt sich da die Frage, warum, was man da auch erwarten soll, was ein solcher Hersteller dann an Verbesserungen mitbringt.
Also die Lücke war so ernsthaft und konzeptuell so kaputt, dass du gesagt hast, da dürfen wir keine Zeit verlieren, das soll dann auch, wenn es an die Öffentlichkeit kommt, Broken by Design.
Also genau, Broken by Design ist ein Punkt. Anderer Punkt ist natürlich, dass sich Leute darauf verlassen, dass das sicher ist. Der nächste Punkt ist, dass da ein großes Marketing drumrum lief. Sie sind halt in mehreren Zeitungen gewesen, also auch so eher consumerorientierte Blätter wie Computerbild oder sonst irgendwas haben darüber berichtet und auch sehr positiv darüber berichtet. Man muss natürlich dann auch in dem Moment damit rechnen, dass jetzt Benutzer anfangen, auf diesen Zug aufzuspringen. Genau wie das bei WhatsApp ist, da ist darüber diskutiert worden, ja, das ist alles unsicher, am besten sollten wir das alles lassen, aber meine ganzen Freunde sind da. Wenn man erst mal an diesen Punkt angekommen ist, und das kann sich innerhalb von ein, zwei Monaten ganz zügig ändern, dann ist es einfach zu spät.
Ja, also ich meine, das Ding, was er eben anspricht, ist meiner Meinung nach einfach Fahrlässigkeit, weil denen der Öffentlichkeit einfach suggeriert wird, ja, wir haben hier Probleme mit Überwachung durch Staat und irgendwelche anderen Organisationen, also brauchen wir verschlüsselte Systeme, um zu kommunizieren, und wir haben da mal was gebaut. Und am Ende sind die Benutzer, die klicken dann auf genau das, was am breitesten in den Medien und in der Öffentlichkeit bereitgetreten wird, weil die gar nicht einschätzen können, was da eigentlich technisch dahinter steckt. Und man kann da so viel falsch machen. Ich bin halt einfach der Meinung, wenn man davon keine Ahnung hat, sollte man eben die Finger davon lassen und auch eben nicht so agieren. Das ist eben einfach fahrlässig. Gerade wenn dann eben diese ganzen tollen Crypto-Partys stattfinden, die ja an sich gut sind, aber manchmal kann man halt einfach auch nicht einschätzen, was steckt eigentlich technisch im Detail hinter dem, was ich da jetzt empfehle zur Absicherung der Kommunikation. Weil vielleicht am Ende irgendwelche Journalisten oder politisch aktiven Menschen in irgendwelchen Regionen mit dieser Software am Ende arbeiten und am Ende ihr Leben riskieren, weil das System vielleicht doch nicht so sicher ist. Vor diesem Whistle-EM gab es ja irgendwie diese Crypto-Cat-Nummer, wo zum Beispiel der Programmierer, der das initiiert hat, einfach mal ganz anders umgegangen ist mit den Problemen, nachdem das veröffentlicht wurde. Ich will das jetzt nicht vorgreifen, aber ich möchte jetzt einfach noch mal zurückkommen zu diesem Whistle-EM, weil sich das schon sehr stark unterscheidet. Wie reagieren die Hersteller am Ende auf so eine Anschuldigung?
Das würde ich jetzt gerade erstmal den Nexus fragen wollen. Das hatten wir noch gar nicht.
Bevor du jetzt mit der nächsten Frage kommst, ich gehe da jetzt nochmal kurz zwischen. So eine Sache, die mir auch sehr aufgefallen ist, ist diese aggressive Werbung. Man merkt, es sind zwei Studenten, die das entwickelt haben. Man merkt, dass auf das Marketing extrem viel Wert gelegt wurde. Also diese ganze Webseite ist sehr shiny hochgezogen worden und es sah alles sehr toll aus. Und im Text wird beschrieben, dass da auch der Informant dann mit der Presse kommunizieren kann sicher und dass die Idee dahinter ist. Und das ist natürlich ein Punkt, da möchte ich auch nicht mehr davon reden, dass dir jetzt irgendwas vermittelt wird oder dass da was falsch verstanden wird oder dass es nur gefährlich ist, sondern da möchte ich eigentlich an den Punkt kommen, dass das eigentlich schon, ich würde sagen, verarschend von Benutzern ist. Nee, Vorsatz würde ich da nicht unterstellen, das kann ich so nicht. Also ich gehe eher davon aus, dass sie überhaupt nicht wissen, wovon sie reden oder nicht verstehen, wie diese Systeme funktionieren, den technischen Hintergrund nicht haben und dann so etwas aufziehen. Und wenn du jetzt zu der Frage mit dem Umgang kommen möchtest, dann zeigt sich eigentlich, dass das auch der richtige Ansatz war mit dem Full Disclosure.
Ja, das wäre jetzt genau meine nächste Frage. Also wie haben die denn reagiert? Weil das war ja sozusagen für einen Hersteller die schlimmste mögliche Nachricht, die man bekommen kann. Oh mein Gott, das ist alles kaputt.
Also die Sache war, es ist halt irgendwie so übers Internet geleakt. Ich habe das halt abends mal ins Internet gestellt, eigentlich hier so für ein paar Bekannte, die mich darum gebeten hatten, das mal aufzuschreiben. Und morgens habe ich dann mal ein Notebook aufgeklappt und hatte irgendwie knapp 40 neue Mails, wo mir alle möglichen Leute geschrieben haben, ja, das wäre ja total gut und ob ich nicht Alternativen hätte. Darunter war dann auch eine Mail von den Anbietern, das war ja schon mal ganz nett, dass sie sich bei mir gemeldet haben, wo sie mir dann eine Liste von technischen Fragen vorgeworfen haben, wo sie dann von mir mal so eine Bewertung haben wollten, wie sie es denn besser machen können. Also quasi noch Ideen, wie man jetzt damit umgehen könnte.
Willst du uns nicht unser Protokoll neu designen für lau?
Ja genau, genau. Also so ist es irgendwie gewesen. Sie schreiben auf der Webseite, dass die Kryptographie Open Source ist. Als ich das erste Mal da drauf geguckt habe, dachte ich jetzt, oh toll, eine neue Open Source App. Kann ich mal reingucken, wie die so aussieht, und mir dann überlegen, ob das das ist. Musste dann feststellen, dass das zwei JavaScript-Sites, die da offen sind, und da sind die Krypto-Algorithmen drin. Aber da wird auch suggeriert, das ist alles Open Source. Nein, die Teile, die ich auseinandergepflückt habe, sind eben die Teile, die nicht Open Source sind. Das ist tatsächlich die Kommunikation mit dem Server. Aber um zur ursprünglichen Frage zurückzukommen, ich habe dann auf diese Mail geantwortet, was wahrscheinlich im Nachhinein auch ein bisschen ein Fehler war, habe ihnen dann noch zwei, drei neue Sachen gesagt, die mir auch aufgefallen sind, die auch ein Problem sind, die ich gar nicht veröffentlicht habe. Woraufhin sie dann durch die Presse gelaufen sind und erzählt haben, dass sie mit dem Hacker, der das alles aufgedeckt haben, in Kontakt stehen, was so auch nicht stimmt. Ich habe seitdem nie wieder was von denen gehört. Sie sind auch durch die Gegend gelaufen und haben gesagt, dass mit dem kaputten Random Number Generator, also dem Zufallszahlen Generator, das wussten sie auch schon alles. Das habe ich ihnen nämlich mitgeteilt in meiner Mail. Und naja, der andere Punkt ist, sie haben bis heute ihre Benutzer nicht darüber informiert, dass es da ein Problem gab und dass eigentlich alle Nachrichten, die über dieses System ausgetauscht wurden, niemals sicher ausgetauscht wurden. Auch in dieser Zwischenphase, wo sie an dem Patch gearbeitet haben, um genau diese Sachen, also tatsächlich so ein, naja, wir haben jetzt hier so ein paar Punkte, die lösen wir mal, dann geht das alles schon wieder. In dieser Zwischenzeit, das wurde gefunden, und sie haben eine neue Version nach drei Tagen, haben sie nicht ihre Benutzer darüber informiert, dass da ein Problem vorliegt, obwohl sie das wissentlich, also sie wussten es, dass das so ist. Das wäre für mich vielleicht ein Punkt gewesen, wo ich hätte sagen müssen, ich muss die Server ausschalten. Vielleicht kommuniziert da jetzt jemand sicher, oder denkt, er ist jetzt sicher, und jemand anderes liest das mit.
Ist die Software jetzt deiner Einschätzung nach jetzt sicher, oder?
Naja, ich habe sie mir nicht noch mal angeguckt, aber diese Punkte, die ich gefunden habe, das sind grundlegende Punkte gewesen, das ist etwas, wo nicht mal ein Krypto-Anfänger darüber stolpern sollte. Ich möchte mir nicht ausmalen, wenn man tiefer in die Software guckt, was da los ist. Also den Schritt, den habe ich gar nicht mehr gemacht. Das war an der Stelle so grottig und so grausam, was sich da aufgetan hat. Also ich hätte nicht damit gerechnet, dass ich in meinem Leben noch mal so was sehe.
Also von deiner Seite aus ist das ein Beispiel dafür, dass sowohl die Software nicht gut ist, als auch der Umgang mit der Veröffentlichung noch zu wünschen übrig lässt, sage ich mal, jetzt ganz diplomatisch.
Ja, genau. Also der Punkt ist, als Benutzer möchte ich natürlich wissen, dass da ein Problem besteht. Und ich möchte natürlich auch von meinem Anbieter, vor allem wenn er mir suggeriert, hier ist ein sicheres System, möchte ich darüber informiert werden. Und der einzige Punkt, warum das vielleicht nicht passiert ist, weil man dann hätte auf die Webseite schreiben müssen, so Software ist unsicher, das passt nicht ins Marketingkonzept. Bisher ist diese Software kostenlos, aber sie rennen ja auch durch die Zeitung und sagen, sie wissen noch nicht, wie sie es in Zukunft vermarkten wollen. Also ich gehe mal davon aus, dass da schon finanzielle Aspekte auch im Hintergrund stehen und warum. Also sie haben mir auch auf meine Mail geantwortet, wo sie dann beschrieben haben, warum es nicht open source ist, weil es jetzt gerade so viel Konkurrenz auf dem Markt gibt und sie wollen nicht, dass jemand von ihnen klaut.
Aber klar.
Das lässt so ein bisschen vermuten, dass da schon so langsam diese Idee ist, man könnte da auf Dauer Geld mit verdienen.
Eine Geschichte also, wie der Umgang mit Wendat sein kann. Nexus, vielen Dank.
Bitte schön.
Und viel Spaß noch. Und bitte auch den nächsten Messenger, der das sicherheitsverspricht.
Am Ende haben die ja diese Probleme, die Existenz der Probleme, haben sie ja kommuniziert, aber nur an einen sehr kleinen Kreis, oder?
Ja, sie haben das nur mit der Presse kommuniziert und sie haben auf ihrer Webseite, findet man ganz unten in der Fußzeile, so ein Pressepaket. Also wenn man das runterlädt in diesem ZIP-File, was man dann auspackt, da steht das tatsächlich drin. Und da steht auch, dass sie das alles beseitigt haben und da erklären sie auch irgendwie, wie sie das beseitigt haben, glaube ich grob. Also ich habe das nun mal überflogen.
Und dann stellst du dich hin und sagst, sie haben das nicht öffentlich kommuniziert, ja?
Ja Moment, sie haben es nicht den Usern kommuniziert. Sie haben es öffentlich kommuniziert, klar. Sie haben natürlich von den ganzen Medien wahrscheinlich gleich Mails bekommen, hier, was sagt ihr dazu? Also sie haben ja Heise gegenüber was gesagt, sie haben GoalLab gegenüber was gesagt und so weiter. Also da sind ja schon Antworten gekommen. Sie haben sich auch hingestellt und mir vorgeworfen, ich hätte ja vorher mit ihnen sprechen können. Klar, also da ist schon in den Medien was kommuniziert worden, aber nicht gegenüber den Benutzern. Und das ist genau das, was in der Summe passiert.
Falls Sie das noch nachholen wollen, 031 77 97 110, das ist die Telefonnummer dieser Sendung, könnt ihr gerne noch anrufen, liebe WhistleIRM-Macher. Ja, Nexus, aber gut, das war's jetzt, oder? Vielen Dank. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Tschüss. So, jetzt hattest du Thorsten CryptoCat angesprochen. Was ist das und was kann man da erzählen an dieser Geschichte?
Ja, ich habe mich nicht so sehr im Detail damit beschäftigt. Ich habe das nur am Rande mitbekommen, dass es da eben eine Plattform gab, mit der man verschlüsselt kommunizieren kann und die auch von vielen Leuten empfohlen wurde, dass man die eben benutzt, um verschlüsselt zu kommunizieren. Das ist eben einfach mal so der Hintergrund dahinter. Und das wurde wohl offenbar auch ziemlich vielen Journalisten in Krisenregionen eben auch empfohlen zur Kommunikation. Und dann hatte man da irgendwie schwerwiegende Fehler in der Krypto gefunden oder zumindest in der Implementierung. Und ja, also was ich halt so am Rande mitbekomme, aber ich muss wirklich sagen, ich habe mich da gar nicht so sehr reingekniet, aber das hat ja doch irgendwie mal im Größeren die Runde gemacht. Also der Entwickler dieser Software oder dieses Verfahrens hatte sich dann halt am Ende mit dem ganzen Feedback auseinandergesetzt und hat halt sein Bestes getan, um halt auch zu recherchieren und herauszufinden, wie er das verbessern kann. Und hat sich im Sommer diesen Jahres auf jeden Fall auf der SIGINT, also einer CCC-Veranstaltung in Köln, auch der kritischen Masse gestellt. Er hatte da einen Vortrag drüber gehalten und hat halt auch vor allen Dingen darüber referiert, was für Lehren er aus diesem ganzen Prozess gezogen hat und wie er das halt in Zukunft vermeiden möchte, dass das eben nochmal passiert oder eben wie man eben auch mit so einem Security Advisories dann am Ende auch umgeht. Also da hat er sich irgendwie einmal in einem Talk hat er darüber erzählt und am Ende hat er sogar nochmal außerplanmäßig eben eine Art Diskussion geführt mit den Leuten, die da auch Interesse dran hatten. Das fand ich halt zum Beispiel sehr positiv im Gegensatz zu eben solchen Leuten, über die wir jetzt gerade was gehört haben, wie die eben damit umgehen, wo möglicherweise andere Interessen dahinterstehen. Eben nicht, dass man etwas besser machen will und anderen eine Kommunikationsplattform zur Verfügung stellen will aus reiner nächsten Liebe, sondern dass man dann möglicherweise auch noch erwartet, dass dann irgendwann mal Geld bei abfällt.
Der Krypto-Card ist ja, glaube ich, wenn ich es richtig sehe, auch sozusagen so eine Sache, wo nicht primär Geld mit verdient wird, sondern ist ja glaube ich umsonst. Genau, also Positivbeispiel. So, jetzt hast du ja hier noch eine relativ lange Liste an Dingen mitgebracht, an kleinen Anekdoten, die man vielleicht so halbe erzählen könnte. Es scheint doch alles nicht so einfach zu sein.
Nee, ist auch nicht so einfach. Also, ich meine, viele Sachen, die man zum Beispiel an irgendeinen Hersteller kommuniziert, die findet man möglicherweise ja auch im Rahmen seiner normalen beruflichen Tätigkeit als Sicherheitsberater oder eben jemand, der eben Software zerpflückt und da ganz skizziert nach Fehlern sucht. Also, das ist halt mein Job. Im Grunde genommen kommen halt Kunden von mir an, die sagen, wir wollen in unserem Netzwerk diese und jene Software installieren und ausrollen für alle Benutzer. Das kann dann halt durchaus mehrere Zehntausende Benutzer betreffen, irgendwelche Managementsoftware und so weiter. Und die kommen dann eben zu uns an und sagen, okay, bevor wir uns, bevor wir jetzt hier viel Geld ausgeben und diese Software über uns im Netzwerk installieren, schaut euch doch mal diese Installation an und sagt uns, was ihr davon haltet aus Sicherheitssicht. Weil wir wollen zumindest wissen, auf was für einem Sicherheitsniveau sich dieses Produkt befindet, damit man eben weiß, was man am Ende noch dazu investieren muss, um Sicherheitsrisiken abzuschwächen und eben damit umgehen zu können. Dass man eben mit so einer größeren Komplexität sich auch noch größere Risiken und so Angriffsflächen eben ins eigene Netzwerk holt.
Also es ist gar nicht so, dass man davon ausgeht in diesem Kontext, dass eine Software komplett sicher ist. Man will nur wissen, in welchem Level sie ungefähr operiert.
Ja, ich meine, jemand, der uns mit so etwas beauftragt oder irgendeinen anderen beliebigen Sicherheitsdienstleister, der hat ein gewisses Budget für diese Überprüfung und im Rahmen dieses Budgets kann man dann eben agieren. Manchmal findet man Bugs schneller, manchmal nicht so schnell, manchmal findet man vieler, manchmal weniger. Aber im Endeffekt hat der Kunde, der das beauftragt, auch nur einen Überblick. Wenn ich jetzt zwei Hacker da hinsetze und die dafür bezahle, da drinne Bugs zu finden, dann kostet das so und so viel Geld. Und am Ende kommt das und das raus. Aber im Rahmen solcher Tätigkeiten findet man ja auch an der Regel Bugs, die man dann auch dem Hersteller dieser Software am Ende auch kommuniziert, damit der das Produkt verbessern kann. Da hat dann jeder was davon. Der Kunde von uns, der diese Software kaufen will, der lernt auch gleich mal den Kunden eben von der Seite kennen, wie reagiert der auf so eine Bugreports und wie schnell ist der in der Lage, Patches bereitzustellen und ja.
Und kannst du da Beispiele geben, was dafür passiert ist?
Das Ding ist halt, dass man da natürlich nicht sagen kann, man macht hier Full Disclosure, weil damit tut man ja dann seinen Kunden auch nicht um den großen Gefallen. Das läuft dann alles sehr gesittet ab und in den meisten Fällen kommt es dann auch in der Regel nicht zu irgendwelchen Veröffentlichungen, weil man da manchmal auch Sachen findet, die halt, wo es halt schlecht wäre, die zu veröffentlichen. Aber das ist halt, weiß ich nicht. Also in vielen Fällen findet man halt Sachen, die man auch veröffentlichen kann, aber dann ist man halt in einem sehr engen Kontakt mit diesem Hersteller, dieser Software und fängt da halt jetzt nicht an großartig rumzuzicken. Damit man halt auch, ich meine, das ist ja, man agiert ja da nicht anonym, sondern man hat ja auch einen Ruf. Und wenn wir uns dann da eben professionell verhalten, dann beugen wir uns halt eben den Regeln und müssen halt einfach gucken, dass wir da nicht zu sehr negativ auffallen. Manchmal kommt es dann aber eben zu so einer Situation, wo wir denken, das ist vielleicht einfach nur so ein Beiprodukt von irgendeiner Tätigkeit, die man halt gerade macht, dann findet man irgendeinen völlig banalen Fehler in irgendeinem total weit verbreiteten Betriebssystem für mobile Telefone. Und dann schreibt man einfach einen Blogartikel darüber, wenn man einfach auch nicht einsieht, dass man für so einen banalen Fehler jetzt irgendwie so diesen Prozess mit Responsible Disclosure oder so durchspielt, weil das vielleicht einfach ein bisschen zu... Damit würde man den eigenen Bug, den man da gefunden hat, vielleicht einfach ein bisschen zu sehr pushen und ein bisschen zu stark aufwerten. Und das ist es einfach auch in der Regel nicht wert, gerade bei so was, was wir mal veröffentlicht haben, ist halt, dass wir einfach durch einen Zufall herausgefunden haben, dass bei HTC die Mail-Applikationen SSL-Zertifikate nicht ordentlich validiert und dass man da halt spielend leicht mehr in den Sinn mittel machen kann, also sich einfach in die Kommunikation zwischen dem Telefon und dem Mail-Server einhängen kann.
Obwohl SSL sagen, eigentlich wird die Mail verschlüsselt übertragen, aber das hat einen Fehler, dass man das sozusagen doch abhören kann. Und das habt ihr dann gleich öffentlich gemacht.
Ja, weil das einfach ein völlig banaler Fehler war. Und diesen Fehler, den gab es halt schon mal vor ein paar Jahren und offenbar gab es dann aber einfach viele Benutzer, die sich darüber aufgeregt haben, dass denen häufiger SSL-Warnings angezeigt wurden. Also einfach nur Warnmeldungen, dass irgendwas mit dem SSL-Zertifikat nicht in Ordnung ist. Dass sich HDC am Ende genötigt sah, diese Sicherheitschecks wieder auszuschalten. Das ist halt nichts, was man dann so aus Versehen macht. Wenn das aus Versehen passiert, dann muss man sich schon grundlegend überlegen, was haben die denn da für Softwareentwicklungsprozesse eigentlich? Wie machen die das? Haben die keine Test-Cases? Wenn sie mal einen Bug haben, also in der Regel haben ja so Firmen, die das auch ordentlich machen, die kriegen halt mal eine Bug-Meldung rein, dann bauen die sich einen Test-Case und überprüfen halt jede Revision, die sie veröffentlichen, gegen diese ganzen Test-Cases. Um halt auch zu verhindern, dass der gleiche Fehler nochmal veröffentlicht wird. Also das scheint schon eine sehr mutwillige Sache gewesen zu sein, die wahrscheinlich darauf beruht, dass Benutzer faul sind oder einfach zu blöd sind, Fehlermeldungen durchzulesen. Da haben wir halt gesagt, was sollen wir da ein Advisory machen, das ist halt albern.
Jetzt habt ihr das sozusagen einfach so veröffentlicht, gab es eine Reaktion von der HTC?
Ja, natürlich gab es eine Reaktion. Irgendwann bekamen wir dann halt eine Mail vom Legal Department, die halt so anfingen mit Gentlemen, wir müssen mal über eure Disclosure Policies sprechen. Und ja, also einfach auch nicht unbedingt nett. Aber gut, ich meine, was wir da veröffentlicht haben, war jetzt auch nicht unbedingt nett. Aber ich hielt das halt einfach für albern, da irgendwie so diese Riesenprozedur durchzuziehen mit Irresponsible Disclosure. Da gibt es einfach andere Sachen. Da macht man sich diese Mühe dann halt einfach lieber, weil das einfach vielleicht mehr Impact hat und mehr Spaß macht.
Ist das denn mittlerweile gefixt worden?
Weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Habt ihr denn was, was noch kritischer ist, aber immer noch rumliegt, obwohl ihr schon seit Jahren darauf hinweist?
Was heißt seit Jahren darauf hinweisen?
Ich denke ja an Punkt 4 der ominösen Liste, die niemand kennt.
Ich wollte jetzt ja eigentlich nicht irgendeine Liste abarbeiten, sondern einfach nur... Das ist aber in der Tat einfach ein ganz interessantes Beispiel. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was wir da am Ende für eine Strategie hatten, das zu veröffentlichen. Eigentlich war das mal so Responsible Disclosure ganz am Anfang, aber das ist halt schon ein paar Jahre her. 2009 oder 2008 hatte mein Kollege angefangen, sich mal so Wireless-Keyboards anzugucken von Microsoft. Also einfach so drahtlose Tastaturen, wo man dann eben die batteriebetriebene Tastatur auf einem sauberen Schreibtisch stehen hat. Man tippt eine Taste und magischerweise taucht dann dieser Buchstabe auch auf dem Monitor auf. Da hat er sich halt mal diese angeguckt, wie werden diese Daten eigentlich übertragen und kann man das irgendwie abfangen. Und als er dann ziemlich schnell herausgefunden hat, wie das geht und wie man das abfangen kann, hat er sich da entsprechend halt auch an den Hersteller gewendet, in dem Fall halt Microsoft. Microsoft hat da zwar am Anfang drauf reagiert, aber dann ist das irgendwann auch ziemlich schnell wieder eingeschlafen. Und dann ist er damit halt auf diverse Konferenzen, hat halt Sachen veröffentlicht und Proof of Concept haben wir dann gebaut und veröffentlicht, also einfach ein Stück Hardware gebaut, was in der Lage ist, diese Daten, die übertragen werden, mitzulesen. Wir haben Code veröffentlicht und die Hardware. Und das hat immer noch keinen interessiert. Die Reaktion war halt so, man muss halt in der Nähe sein und das ist ja nicht so richtig remote und überhaupt. Und irgendwann später hat Microsoft eine neue Generation von Keyboards gebaut, die sehr viel zuverlässiger funktionieren. Also diese alten Keyboards basierten auf irgendeinem alten Funk, also so ein Elfmeterband, 27 MHz hatten die halt benutzt, um Daten zu übertragen. Sie hatten halt so einen lustigen XOR-Krypto mit einem Byte-Key.
Was auch immer das bedeutet, also man konnte sehr leicht mithören.
Ja, ja, also es ist halt so wie rot 13 oder so. Also es ist halt wirklich nicht sonderlich, also es ist halt einfach zu analysieren und mitzulesen. Nur irgendwann hatten sie halt neue Geräte gebaut, die hatten irgendwie andere Funktechnik an Bord. Die haben dann eben so eine 2, 4 Gigahertz Funkchips drauf gehabt, die sehr wenig Strom verbrauchen, die sehr schnell sind. Und dann haben sie da damit gearbeitet, haben eine neue Krypto implementiert. Und wir haben uns natürlich dann diese Keyboards auch angesehen und haben halt auch relativ schnell herausgefunden, wie man diesen Verkehr mitlesen kann und wie diese Krypto funktioniert. Da hatten sie halt nicht nur einen einen Byte langen XOR-Key, sondern einen fünf Byte langen XOR-Key.
Das heißt, das ist ein bisschen besser, aber immer noch weiter von entfernt richtig gut zu sein.
Und dieser XOR-Key war gleichzeitig die MAC-Adresse des Gerätes. Und ja, damit war das im Endeffekt Klartext, was da übermittelt wird. Der Vorteil bei diesen Tastaturen war halt, man konnte dadurch, dass man diese Module, die da fürs Senden genutzt werden, die sind halt sehr einfach als Modul zu erwerben oder eben auch zu bauen. Und dann hat man am Ende nicht nur einen Empfänger, dass man alles mitsniffen kann, also mitlesen kann, was da eingetippt wird, wie zum Beispiel Passwörter oder irgendwelche Bankkreditkartennummern und so weiter. Wir konnten auch senden. Das heißt, wenn wir einmal irgendwie herausgefunden haben, wie dieser Crypto-Key aussieht und wie diese MAC-Adresse aussieht, dann konnte man halt auch Code ausführen auf dem PC.
Warte mal, verstehe ich richtig zu sagen, also drahtlose Tastaturen kann man sowohl mitlesen, was da jemand auf der Tastatur schreibt, als auch einfach dem Computer, sagen Signale sind, und so tun, als wäre man die Tastatur.
Ja, ja, genau.
Das geht immer noch?
Das geht immer noch, natürlich. Also, ich meine, je nachdem, was du da für eine Tastatur hast. Aber du kannst im Grunde genommen einfach mit deiner Richtfunkantenne draußen im Auto sitzen, warten, bis der Typ aufs Klo geht. Und dann kannst du sagen, ich bin die Tastatur und jetzt führ mal diesen Befehl aus. Und dann kannst du da irgendeine Schadsoftware ausführen.
Und Microsoft hat dazu gesagt, das ist doch alles nicht so schlimm.
Nö, das haben die so nicht gesagt, aber die haben es halt auch einschlafen lassen. Ich vermute halt einfach, sie sitzen es aus, weil sie einfach nichts tun können. Was sollen sie tun? Also diese Geräte sehen halt nicht vor, da irgendwie Firmware-Updates einzuspielen. Und vermutlich wurden die halt nicht mal selber von Microsoft gebaut, sondern irgendwo eingekauft, kommen halt von irgendwo her. Die Hardware wird irgendwo eingekauft und die Firmware halt auch. Und man kann es halt einfach nicht patchen. Und wenn man es nicht patchen kann, kann man entweder die ganze Produktpalette zurückrufen oder das einfach aussitzen. Und das ist im Grunde genommen das, was passiert ist.
Habt ihr das dann auch schon Full Disclosured?
Ja, das ist alles. Also was heißt Full Disclosure? Tatsächlich haben wir Microsoft davon in Kenntnis gesetzt, dass wir jetzt auch diese Keyboards gehackt haben und dass wir das da und da veröffentlichen werden. Aber ich meine, die Leute sind ja nicht unfreundlich mit uns. Sie haben halt auch darauf reagiert, aber am Ende heißt es halt so, man muss in der Nähe sein und damit ist die Sache hier.
Okay, was sind eure Tests? Was heißt in der Nähe?
Also in der Nähe heißt es halt irgendwie so, je nach Gebäude, also was das für Fenster und Wände sind, können es durchaus 20, 30, 40, 50 Meter sein.
Ein schönes Beispiel für eine Sicherheitslücke, wo vielleicht ein bisschen mehr öffentliche Aufmerksamkeit noch wünschenswert wäre. So, wir haben gleich noch eine halbe Stunde für Sicherheitslücken und im Umgang machen aber jetzt eine kurze Pause hier im Chaosradio mit dem Fritz Info mit Nachrichten, Wetter und Verkehr.
In unserer Reihe absolute Superstars. Montag, 28. Einer von die absoluten Superstars.
Mit Philipp Berger. Die 5 UN-Veto-Mächte USA, Großbritannien, Frankreich, Russland und China beraten gerade über die Krise in Syrien. Sie diskutieren über einen britischen Resolutionsentwurf, der einen Militäreinsatz erlauben würde. Daran heißt es, es müssten alle notwendigen Maßnahmen zum Schutz von Zivilpersonen vor Giftgas ergriffen werden. Nach den Worten des britischen Premierministers Cameron gibt es keine eindeutigen Beweise, dass der syrische Machthaber Assad den mutmaßlichen Chemiewaffeneinsatz angeordnet hat. Er, Cameron, sei aber von der Schuld der Regierung in Damaskus überzeugt, sagte der britische Regierungschef im Parlament in London. In Brandenburg gibt es offenbar mehr Opfer rechtsextremistischer Gewalt als bisher angenommen. Bei Recherchen des Potsdamer Moses Mendelsohn Zentrums sind neun zusätzliche Verdachtsfälle aufgetaucht. Die Wissenschaftler untersuchen im Auftrag des Innenministeriums derzeit 31 Tötungsverbrechen seit der Wende, bei denen von einem rechtsextremistischen Hintergrund ausgegangen wird. Dabei stießen die Forscher auf diese weiteren neun Verdachtsfälle. Die Grünen in Berlin haben einen Antrag für eine offizielle Marihuana-Verkaufsstelle im Görlitzer Park in Kreuzberg gestellt. Das Bezirksparlament von Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg muss den Antrag für dieses Modellprojekt jetzt prüfen. In dem Laden soll, wie in den niederländischen Coffee-Shops, Cannabis kontrolliert verkauft werden. Im Görlitzer Park gibt es seit Jahren illegalen Drogenhandel. In letzter Zeit häufen sich Polizeirazzien. Anwohner sagen, dass die Zahl der Dealer und Konsumenten zugenommen hat. Jugendliche haben in Deutschland deutlich weniger Freizeit als noch vor drei Jahren. Das zeigt der aktuelle Freizeitmonitor, den die Stiftung für Zukunftsfragen in Berlin vorgestellt hat. Durchschnittlich vier Stunden Freizeit pro Tag haben Jugendliche. Das sind knapp 50 Minuten weniger als noch vor drei Jahren. Die Autoren der Studie erklären das damit, dass es immer mehr Ganztagsschulen gibt und dass der Leistungsdruck allgemein gestiegen sei, z.B. durch das Abi in zwölf Jahren. Zudem hätten Jugendliche heute mehr Termine und stünden unter dem Druck, ständig online aktiv zu sein. Fußball-Bundesligist Eintracht Frankfurt hat die Gruppenphase der Europa League erreicht. Die Hessen gewannen das Playoff-Rückspiel gegen Karabach Akdam aus Aserbaidschan mit 2 zu 1. Der VfB Stuttgart dagegen hat den direkten Einzug in die Europa League verpasst. Die Schwaben kamen gegen Rijeka aus Kroatien nicht über ein 2 zu 2 hinaus. Stuttgart könnte mit Glück morgen als Ersatz für den türkischen Vizemeister Fenebahce Istanbul ausgelost werden und somit durch die Hintertür doch noch am Wettbewerb teilnehmen. Berlin-Wilmersdorf, 14 Grad, Treptow genauso, Forst 10, Angermünde 13, Rate nur 15 und Frankfurt oder 16 Grad. Kälter als 9 Grad soll diese Nacht nicht werden. Am Freitag dann Morgen gibt's viel Sonne und nur wenige Wolken bei maximal 25 Grad. Es bleibt trocken. Am Wochenende verdichten sich die Wolken, die Sonne scheint nur noch selten. Dabei nimmt es zum Sonntag hin die Regenwahrscheinlichkeit zu und es wird kühler. Berlin A100, der Stadtring in Richtung Wedding. Zwischen Beusselstraße und Seestraße gibt's stockenden Verkehr. Und Neukölln A100, Stadtring bis 5 Uhr früh finden im Britzertunnel Wartungsarbeiten statt. Deshalb ist der Stadtring statt Einwärts zwischen Buschkukallee und Oberlandstraße gesperrt. Treptow die Kiefholzstraße, da ist nur eine Spur frei in beiden Richtungen zwischen Baumschulenweg, Baumschulenstraße und Rigsdorfer Straße. Und ein Hinweis für morgen früh Moabit, die Turmstraße wird zwischen Strom- und Waldstraße ab 6 Uhr früh bis einschließlich Sonntag wegen eines Straßenfestes in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. Busse werden umgeleitet. Gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr einen ganz bestimmten Song aus der Fritz-Playlist sucht, dann seht sie euch doch einfach an. Die Playlist auf fritz.de. Und das Auge hört mit manchen.
Heute Chaosradio mit Thorsten und Andreas Hallo und guten Abend. Noch mal zum letzten Mal.
Hallo.
Noch mal hallo.
Sehr schön macht ihr das. Und es geht heute um die Veröffentlichung von Sicherheitslücken. Das heißt, wie geht man eigentlich damit um, wenn man so eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden hat? Und wie reagieren die Firmen darauf? Und wir haben gerade schon gehört nicht immer so gut. Wir haben vielleicht noch ein paar kleine Geschichten. Und ich möchte jetzt auch noch aufrufen, anzurufen. Das heißt, wenn ihr noch etwas nicht verstanden habt oder genauer erklärt haben wollt, dann könnt ihr nochmal anrufen. Oder wenn ihr selber Geschichten habt über lustige Computerfehler, die zu seltsamen Bedienelementen führten. 0331 70 97 11 Zoll. Wir hören hier erst noch mal eine kleine Musik, und zwar Amen von Lim. Eimen von Liem hier im Chaos Radio auf Fritz, wo es heute um die Bekanntgabe von Sicherheitsglücken geht, nachdem wir den theoretischen Teil geklärt haben. Also was da wem passieren kann, haben wir noch vielleicht die eine oder andere kleine Geschichte zum Ende der Sendung. Thorsten, du hast jetzt noch eine kleine Geschichte, wo du gar nicht sagen darfst, um wen es da geht, aber die trotzdem spannend ist.
Naja, spannend nicht. Aber das ist halt einfach so ein typisches Beispiel, wo man sich dann einfach echt ärgert, wie diese Kommunikation mit diesem Softwarehersteller läuft, der von sich behauptet, bislang noch keine Sicherheitslücken gehabt zu haben.
Aha, okay, wir haben also einen Softwarehersteller, der behauptet, noch keine Sicherheitslücke gehabt zu haben. Was habt ihr da gefunden? Eine Sicherheitslücke?
Ja, natürlich haben wir eine Sicherheitslücke gefunden, die eigentlich total trivial auch wiederum ist, auch trivial zu fixen eigentlich. Aber der Impact ist halt relativ hoch bei dem. Wir hatten dann mit diesem Hersteller Kontakt aufgenommen. Wir wurden quasi beauftragt von einem Kunden, der diese Software potenziell einsetzen möchte. Wir sollen uns das mal angucken. Wir haben das natürlich dann alles mit unserem Kunden besprochen. Wie gehen wir auf den Hersteller dieser Software zu? Das wurde dann koordiniert mit dem Kunden. Dann gucken wir einfach, wie reagieren die?
Ihr habt einen Kunden, der eine Software kaufen will, will aber sicher gehen, dass sie gut ist. Deswegen beauftragt er euch, diese Software anzugucken. Der Kunde besorgt die Software, gibt die euch. Dann habt ihr den Fehler gefunden, habt das aber erst mal mit dem Kunden besprochen.
Genau. Dann arbeiten wir zusammen mit dem Kunden eine Strategie aus, wie wir den Hersteller dieser Software darüber informieren, weil wir wollen natürlich, dass er die Probleme behebt. Wir wollen natürlich auch lernen, wie verhält er sich mit Problemen. Wie reagiert er, wie schnell kann man mit Patches rechnen. Das war eigentlich alles total entspannt. Es gab dann Telefonkonferenzen und E-Mails ohne Ende, wo immer wieder gesagt wird, wie wir vorgehen. Wir werden das dann auch veröffentlichen, damit andere Nutzer dieser Software die Gelegenheit bekommen, über so einen schwerwiegenden Fehler informiert zu werden. Das ging ja noch mal so hin und her. Dann hat man ja irgendwie so eine Zeitlinie, die man dann auch immer wieder neu kommuniziert und abstimmt. Dann sagen alle ja, ja und alles ist gut. Dann sagt man, wenn ihr einen Patch habt, dann werden wir das veröffentlichen und nicht vorher, weil das ist so verantwortungsvoll. Wir veröffentlichen den Kram erst, wenn ihr einen Patch habt. Irgendwann hat der Hersteller gesagt, alles klar, wir haben das Problem verstanden, wir haben das Problem behoben, wir haben hier einen Patch, den kann man ausrollen. Dann sagen wir, alles klar, dann können wir in zwei Wochen veröffentlichen. Und dann fängt es an komisch zu werden, weil dann heißt es auf einmal so, wie ihr wollt das veröffentlichen? Wo wollt ihr das veröffentlichen? Ich will nur sicherstellen, dass das jetzt nicht auf irgendeiner öffentlichen Webseite veröffentlicht wird. Tat dann halt ganz überrascht und fing dann halt an, da rum zu diskutieren. Also nur mal so von einem juristischen Standpunkt aus betrachtet, seid ihr euch wirklich sicher, dass ihr euch da nicht irgendwie juristische Probleme bereitet? Also ich meine, ich bin jetzt kein Anwalt, aber ich könnte ja unsere Anwälte mal fragen, was die dazu sagen würden, wenn ihr anfängt, da jetzt hier Fehler zu veröffentlichen. Weil wir haben ja in unseren Geschäftsbedingungen ja auch stehen, dass man die Software nicht reverse engineern darf und dass man da nicht gezielt nach unseren Geheimnissen suchen darf und so weiter und so ging das dann halt los. Und dann ging das Ganze schon wieder auf irgendwie so eine juristische Schiene. Und bei uns ist dann natürlich so, also im Endeffekt war so die Kernaussage von diesen Kunden sinngemäß an uns gerichtet, einen schönen Kunden haben sie da, das wäre doch schade, wenn diesem Kunden irgendwas zustößt. Ich meine, sie haben uns im Endeffekt unter Druck gesetzt, weil wir natürlich Gefahr laufen, unseren Kunden zu verlieren, der uns ja bezahlt dafür. Und ich meine, das ist halt einfach dann echt, das riecht dann halt einfach nach Schlammschlacht. Und das ist einfach total ätzend, wenn die dann anfangen, überrascht zu tun. Und da hat man dann auch irgendwann keine Freude mehr dran und denkt sich einfach nur so, hey, jetzt das Ding einfach irgendwie anonym veröffentlichen oder was weiß ich, das wäre halt eine total tolle Sache, kann man natürlich nicht machen. Aber es ist halt schon dann echt mühsam da, irgendwie locker zu bleiben.
Gibt es da schon eine Lösung des Problems oder ist das quasi noch im Schwange?
Das ist total unklar, informiert uns ja dann jetzt auch nicht.
Wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich daran schuld, wenn so ein Fehler dann in die Öffentlichkeit kommt? Also gibt es das wirklich? Also kann ja tatsächlich noch passieren, irgendjemand anderes sagt hier selber Fehler, zack Öffentlichkeit. Wer wird denn dann dafür verantwortlich gemacht? Geht das überhaupt?
Werden wahrscheinlich dann irgendwelche Gerichte klären, keine Ahnung. Also was halt total ätzend ist, wenn man eben auf so eine Firmen zugeht und sagt, die wollen, also man hat da einen Fehler, dann kommen die halt gleich mit so diesen Geheimhaltungsvereinbarungen an und so weiter. Das ist halt Gang und Gebe. Also da werden schon einige Leute von Anfang an mundtot mitgemacht und damit gibt man quasi die Möglichkeit schon mal ab, überhaupt irgendwas zu veröffentlichen, weil die haben dann einfach alles gegen dich in die Hand, in der Hand. Und das kann dann einfach um viel Geld gehen.
Das heißt, die nehmen erst, bevor überhaupt was geredet wird, hier Zettel auf dem Tisch, unterschreib mal.
Was total hirnrissig ist, weil du kriegst ja keine Information von dem Softwarehersteller, du gibst dem Softwarehersteller Information über Fehler, die er noch nicht kennt. Also es ist einfach eine verkehrte Welt, aber das ist halt so eine Realität. Und da muss man halt einfach aufpassen, wenn man da auch unerfahren ist, so eine Dinge zu submetten, also einfach dem auf Hersteller zuzugehen.
Okay, das ist die juristische Keule. Andreas hat noch eine Geschichte mitgebracht, wie man es nicht macht, wenn man der ist, der den Fehler rausgefunden hat.
Eine kleine Warnung an Leute da draußen. Ich will nicht vergemeinern, aber es gibt manche Nerds, die kennen Subtext nicht, die sprechen einfach Klartext. Und da kam eines Tages jemand zu einer großen Firma und sagte, schön guten Tag, ich habe deine Sicherheitslücke gefunden, das und das. Und ich will euch ja nicht erpressen, aber es wäre schön, wenn ich ein bisschen Geld dafür sehen würde. Er meinte das wörtlich genau so.
Er meinte tatsächlich im vollen Ernst, ich will euch nicht erpressen, aber wenn ihr mir was springen lasst, das wäre schon cool.
Genau, das meinte er. Das war sozusagen das, was er versuchte zu sagen. Aber was natürlich irgendwie als Subtext rüberkam, ist, ich will euch sehr wohl erpressen. Ja, und das endete dann damit, dass er also kein Geld bekommen hat und auch kein Ansehen, sondern irgendwie 40 Tagessätze gemeinnützige Arbeit ableisten musste. Weil da kam dann gleich das LKA und die ganze Nummer.
Das war also nicht irgendeine Wald-
und Wiesn-Firma? Das war, nee, das war ein großes deutsches Unternehmen, ja.
So machen wir es also nicht.
Genau, also so größere Unternehmen haben dann Corporate Security und das sind auch Leute, die nicht so ganz die nettesten Zeitgenossen sind.
Jetzt stellt man sich die Frage, also klar, wenn man wie Thorsten in der Firma arbeitet, hat man damit eh zu tun, aber wie ist denn das jetzt, wenn man so aufstrebender Junghacker ist und sich so ein System mal angeguckt hat, so eine Software, und denkt, da ist ja ganz schön was kaputt. Wir hatten ganz am Anfang die Möglichkeit besprochen, dass man auch versuchen kann, so was zu verkaufen, was aber sozusagen aus moralischen Gründen verwerflich ist. Ist das eigentlich so? Ich habe es jetzt gerade so festgelegt. Seht ihr das auch so?
Wer ist denn der Käuferkreis? Was schätzt du denn? Wer kauft denn Software-Schwachstellen?
Ihr habt mir vorhin erklärt, Software-Schwachstellen kaufen entweder Kriminelle oder Regierungen, die damit schöne Überwachungssoftware bauen. Deswegen habe ich auch gerade festgelegt, ich finde es moralisch verwerflich. Aber ist das Konsens?
Das ist nicht ganz Konsens. Es gibt da Leute, die sagen, ach, moralisch, moralisch, mir alles egal, so ist ja irgendwie mein Geld. Oder irgendwie, besonders in den USA verbreitet, aber gibt es auch woanders aufrechte Patrioten, die sagen, natürlich müssen wir irgendwie die Terroristen hacken. Natürlich müssen dazu Waffen gebaut werden und ich baue hier die Waffen, um die Terroristen zu hacken.
Okay, gut, das kann man also machen und ich finde es trotzdem nicht empfehlenswert. Und dann ist es mit dieser Veröffentlichung, die aber, wenn ich euch jetzt richtig verstanden habe, schon sehr steinig sein kann. Was ist denn für euch, wenn jemand, der so sagen, der keine Erfahrung damit hat, aber jetzt über so ein Ding gestolpert ist, die Möglichkeit, das zu machen? Also irgendwie Nexus haben wir gehört, der hat ja sozusagen einfach mal einen Blogpost geschrieben, den Hubs ganz schnell ganz viel Öffentlichkeit gemacht hat, war vielleicht auch sozusagen ein bisschen schnell. Er meinte auch, das sei so halb schief gegangen oder war gar nicht so geplant. Was ist denn jetzt ein guter Weg mit so einer Sache umzugehen?
Na ja, wenn man selbst schon von sich den Eindruck hat, dass man vielleicht diesem Druck nicht standhalten kann, dann sollte man sich vielleicht jemanden suchen, mit dem man das gemeinsam einfach mal durchspielen kann, einfach durchdiskutieren kann, einfach jemand, der vielleicht auch einen Namen hat. Ich meine, es gab ja häufiger eben Situationen, wo man eben gerade bei so größeren Geschichten, die halt auch durchaus Impact haben oder die eben einen finanziellen Schaden bei bestimmten Firmen hervorrufen könnten, dass man dann sich einfach jemanden sucht, der einen dabei so ein bisschen unterstützt, der auch ein bisschen vielleicht bekannter ist oder halt auch über entsprechende Mittel verfügt, etwaige juristische Verfahren ein bisschen finanziell abzufangen oder abzufedern.
Hört es sich jetzt an nach einer Telefonsilzsorge für Junghacker?
Tatsächlich bieten wir das auf dem Kongress regelmäßig an. Da gibt es also so ein Telefon, wo man anrufen kann und sagen kann, ich habe gehackt was jetzt und bekommt dann diskrete Beratungen, wie man aus der Nummer möglichst elegant rauskommt.
Aber im Ernst, ist der Chaos Computer Club da jetzt Ansprechpartner, dass man sagen kann, ich habe eine krasse Sicherheitslücke bei Betriebssystem XY gefunden, traue mich aber nicht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Ist auch schon mehr verfolgt.
Ich meine, guck dir den Staatstrojaner an. Es ist ja im Grunde genommen eine ähnliche Sache. Also jemand weiß halt nicht, da kann halt was sein. Und wie gehen wir eigentlich daran? Was machen wir damit? Also wir brauchen einen technischen Sachverstand. Wir müssen das irgendwie kommunizieren können. Und wir brauchen irgendwie eine Organisation, die in der Lage ist, das, was da möglicherweise kommen mag, irgendwie abzufedern. Also das ist halt ein gutes Beispiel. Aber es gab ja auch irgendwie andere Projekte, wo der CCC sich im Endeffekt auch dahinter gestellt hat und geholfen hat, eben Dinge zu veröffentlichen und so ein bisschen das Rückgrat gebildet hat von Dingen, die dann veröffentlicht wurden. Ich weiß nicht, diese Wahlstifte waren eine Nummer, glaube ich, wo der CCC halt auch irgendwie sich da engagiert hat und Dinge getan hat, die ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt so das Paradebeispiel dafür.
Also man kann aber, wenn man sowas entdeckt hat, schon zu euch kommen.
Ja natürlich, aber man sollte sich vielleicht schon auch überlegen, dass man eben nicht mit jedem Quatsch irgendwie gleich so ein großes Fass aufmachen sollte. Also wie ich schon meinte, es gibt durchaus auch Dinge, wo ich mir sage, das ist einfach völlig banal, da braucht man diesen Aufwand nicht treiben, das ist halt Pille-Palle. Und da muss man schon selber so ein bisschen abschätzen können. Also ich meine, man muss jetzt nicht wegen irgendeinem SQL-Injection-Bug in irgendeiner Web-Software dann irgendwie anfangen, hier mit dem CCC in Kontakt zu treten. Das sollte man vielleicht...
Also wenn man einfach nur eine Webseite aufmacht, dann kann man das einfach dahin mehlen, meinst du?
Nein, CCC hat ja keine... Naja, ist halt nicht so die Seelsorge in dem Sinne. Also ich meine, wenn man irgendwo eine Webseite aufmacht, ja...
Dann ist halt die Webseite auf.
Dann ist die halt auf. Ja, das passiert tausendfach täglich.
Also wenn man Cross-Site-Scripting bei was auch immer für ein Mindestthema auf der Webseite findet, dann kann man das einfach direkt ans PSI melden. Das ist auch in Ordnung. Da passiert auch nichts Schlimmes. Aber wenn es jetzt etwas ist, wo man sich überlegt, so gleich kommen die schwarzen Hubschrauber und Leute seilen sich ab, dann...
Ja, und ich meine, in den USA wurde das ja im Grunde genommen legitimiert. Ich meine, wenn das irgendwie Hacker gibt, die Informationen über Schwachstellen veröffentlichen oder Exploits veröffentlichen, die geeignet sind, die Sicherheit der Vereinigten Staaten zu gefährden und die kritischen Infrastrukturen, da gab es doch irgendwie diesen Beschluss, dass dann eben dieses Kriegsrecht ausgesprochen wird. Und die dann eben ausgelöscht werden können. Also ich meine, das ist halt so der Worst Case in dem Fall.
Hoffen wir, dass euch das nicht passiert. So viel also zur Veröffentlichung von Sicherheitslücken oder zum fachgerechten Umgang mit Herrschaftswissen, könnte man auch sagen. Ihr habt noch zwei kleine Termine mitgebracht, die ihr erzählen wollt, was der CCC so plant.
Genau, eigentlich drei Termine. Zum einen, siebter, neunter ist wieder die Freiheit statt Angst-Demo hier in Berlin. Und wie immer seid ihr alle aufgerufen zu kommen und zu zeigen, dass das mit der Überwachung nicht so toll ist und ihr dagegen seid, wenn euch die NS-Album Telefonsext zuhört.
Dann gibt es noch die MRM CD 2013 in Darmstadt, die am 6. September beginnt.
Was ist das?
Die Meta Rhein-Main-Chaos-Days, das ist sozusagen eine regionale Veranstaltung rund um Frankfurt, Darmstadt, Mainz und wie die Orte da alle heißen.
Und dann haben wir die weniger familiäre Veranstaltung, die da heißt...
Wer hat doch schon wieder jemand sein Handy angemacht?
Ich bin es nicht. Unschuldig. Der 30. Chaos Communication Congress 30C3 in Hamburg steht an und das gibt ein Call for Paper und ihr seid alle noch aufgerufen fleißig Content zu submitten zu den zahlreichen Themen, die wir da halt wie immer haben, also Technik, Politik, Soziales, Kunst, Wissenschaft.
Also wenn ihr noch ein Thema habt für den Chaos Communication Congress, könnt ihr es noch eindanken.
Schickt das bitte rum.
Um die Tickets muss man sich ja also noch keine Sorgen machen.
Ich glaube nicht, aber ich weiß, dass der Kongress auf jeden Fall ziemlich cool werden wird dieses Jahr sowohl von der Location her, also letztes Jahr war die Location ja irgendwie neu für alle, aber es war eine sehr schöne Veranstaltung und ich hoffe, dass es halt dieses Jahr inhaltlich auch noch mehr zu bieten gibt. Das heißt, es wird alles noch ein bisschen größer und mehr Leute und naja, schickt uns mal ein paar coole Paper, damit wir da eine schöne Auswahl haben.
Und vorher hören wir uns aber wahrscheinlich noch in dem einen oder anderen Chaosradio. Das waren Andreas und Thorsten. Vielen Dank euch und viel Spaß noch.
Danke.
Und wir übergeben an Flo Heiler, der jetzt gleich im Night Flight euch mit Punkmusik bewerfen wird. Ihr könnt den ganzen Podcast nochmal nachhören. Auf Fritz, ihr erscheint diese Nacht auf Chaosradio.ccc.de ein bisschen später, aber wird auf jeden Fall auch irgendwann verfügbar sein. Falls ihr noch Anmerkungen habt, gerne auch im dazugehörigen Blog in die Kommentarfunktion schreiben oder an Chaosradio.ccc.de. Mein Name ist Markus Richter und ich hab nur noch eine Nachricht für euch. Macht immer schön eure, ne, lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.